hey let's go bro Smitty's this is some
footage of me and Brad play or sorry
marzia playing at player unknown
battlegrounds I wasn't planning for this
to be a video my webcam wasn't recording
but I think you guys are gonna find it
pretty interesting we're literally just
hanging out and not really thinking
about that this should be a video so
it's very you just watch Hillary Clinton
I think I can see one down the road
someone just subscribe to my YouTube
stream because I got the Hillary Clinton
sound Hillary Clinton I have OBS open
that's so [ __ ] it happened twice
are we going good for that that
beginning yeah
oh [ __ ] we're in the blue
yeah
I hate this [ __ ] car purchase it
against you
as a G you want the Jeep yeah
because I will flip it in that car and
house as I can drive
yeah we got a long way to go buddy I
know okay fine
this blue doesn't have very much
you take an energy drink in this fast
blue if factor basically doesn't argue I
don't like it
people shoot you when you're in the car
you're dead scary yeah
I had one game where I can't fight
people with a car it was the best yeah I
[ __ ] love that when you just go
Carmageddon [ __ ] yeah we're just looking
for people that like we're running out
of the blue it was hilarious
okay well
I'm gonna go plane went over the middle
didn't answer
time's up Mich pens down
no more ink no more ink [ __ ] naive it
says you know what I actually had her I
hated him the whole season season 8 we
watch season 8 I hated him all season
and then I was screaming because I knew
he was gonna pick Kelly's tattoo because
she did him right in the end yeah yeah
I'm like this forget I hate him and then
he's like yeah and then he didn't and
I'm like I have so much respect for you
thing I really didn't want her to win
just because she had that thing yeah cuz
I felt the same I was like ah they're
gonna pick that one this is him
yeah yeah no it was the [ __ ] best
they just [ __ ] left it I'm so glad
I'm like cuz they're all one was bad
yeah it was
oh never in the belly ah ah
where are you huh I don't know I'm just
driving cuz I know every time I let you
look up I'm like okay where are we
dangerous where it should we go I'm
gonna head to so there's a couple of
houses along this road think it's do you
think it's good to be there seems like a
terrible place to be I want to be in the
middle we're not in the [ __ ] middle
now listen houses down here with like a
pretty good perch and there always are
people in there so we got to fight our
way in
yeah great way I have a half help yeah
it's a bad idea for there
I'm just checking for open doors okay
well obviously
these ones on on the hill on the left
coming up these are all close that
orange one yeah but they're dangerous
that one by an outsider well this seems
like a terrible idea there's a car here
a bike I don't like it this is this is
[ __ ] madness people now yeah melee
look around
car behind us oh [ __ ] is it stopping no
it's not they stopped yeah they're
coming around they're gonna come and get
us
get in this house this has been looted
we just have to hope there's no one in
the actual yeah I'm coming the bombs
will cover us going in okay no one in
the house close all the doors on the way
up that's you in the building right yeah
I'm upstairs
well here's me Hey so this one has a
pretty good round like a nephew one of
us goes down to this next floor down
here that's praise better you out
everywhere yeah and you know when
someone's coming in and there's three
floors for them to have to fight up well
they have a fight and it's pretty
central so I'm a fan of these
three-story buildings we can get up I'm
a big fan of the ones that properly open
up to the very I think you can jump down
and [ __ ] with them yeah this one has it
an escape route on the side
apparently they're [ __ ] the non
barred windows they're adding a patch
soon where you can just jump for him I
saw that that looks dope as [ __ ]
it does look dope but it does mean also
that you're not gonna be able to predict
whether there's someone in a house
anymore yeah if you know someone's in a
house yeah you can usually predict that
they're what they're gonna do now and
it's like so we know they're in the
other building I have a feeling that
there's someone here well we saw this
building next we saw his what we saw so
out here two teams just had a fight that
one that we just saw yeah drove over
here and then got into a fight with
another team Oh Rebecca
I don't see it oh it's here it's
stopping and stepping outside okay it's
gonna come up yeah don't move don't walk
they're gonna hear you
they're gonna get me I'm coming down
here to pick me up yeah are they coming
in tell me talk to me oh they're coming
in they're coming in I'm trying to walk
down without making noise I think they
heard you [ __ ] my whole plan is over
you're dead
yeah they grenading are you flashed nope
did we have an escape room no there's
one right next to us here on this level
a date over the other house you mean
they didn't actually go for our house
they come one down no trap nice got him
yeah that was [ __ ] ass that one I
like this one oh man is he got sniper
rifle please [ __ ] dude this guy had a
lot of [ __ ] on him [ __ ] was he doing all
this he's got a he's got a suppressor
for a sniper in his pocket suppress her
everything else no I got nothing this is
garbage think he had a lot of [ __ ] he
looted everything what a [ __ ] spaz
what is he gonna do with all this [ __ ]
he had a this one's got a level-two vest
if you need one well yeah
why is my bag so full yeah you should
you should check this guy because I
don't know what the [ __ ] I still
think there's another team over here
somewhere they say well they check the
other bit link no these guys came
straight in on the bike who came in to
us I still think there's another team
that were here before we got here they
just play any safe hmm
well let's not [ __ ] die then yeah 47
bandages
I need 5.56 am I know [ __ ] me [ __ ]
love the shotgun who wrecks at this
distance is it bird the too much yeah
yeah yeah if you a suit if you can you
can rapid fire that yeah if you just go
bang bang yeah it's [ __ ] all and I
know perfectly on target it's just an
instant kill it's [ __ ] beautiful yeah
it was I know you did yeah I can't
assault rifle this distance I always
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah it's just it's
weird like a lot of people saying they
want a training mode in this game like
where you can just shoot with dummies
and practice target practice kind of
thing mmm I actually don't want it
because I mean some I feel like I've
earned the ability to shoot people
because you have to get into a fight
with someone you can loot up all day and
play the hiding game to the final circle
but you pretty much always have to learn
how to kill someone by the end hmm so
getting into fights with people and
shooting them and killing them is fill I
feel like I've earned the honor I've
actually been able to shoot on target
right by getting into real-life fights
and risking that myself yeah it annoys
ya that they're considering putting this
training thing in and I'm like no please
don't
yeah you just don't know it's weird you
just get used to each thing and I think
that's why people like certain guns
because you get used to a certain gun
right I like that the guns are actually
different as well they're not just
classically skins that make sense I
don't see anyone I don't like it what
scopes do you have read up that's it do
you want on four times yes unless you
need it no cuz I can put on eight times
on the m16 and I can read dot with the
AEK okay well I would just like a four
time to alternate between thank you yeah
it makes sense
from from these houses is four times is
pretty much necessary but I can eight
times therefore now some people unlike
milling he's on the balcony okay I got
shot come upstairs I can't get past you
okay I got a hill I gotta here I [ __ ]
I'll just pulled up outside
well [ __ ] yeah come into this one
first my grandma's self no I threw her
Nadine the other bailing that was then
they threw a smoke grenade in here I
don't know where they are I have no idea
all right they're probably outside you
watch you watch that window and I'll
watch the door here wish me know you try
and get them because they might be
hiding in their house I'm pretty sure
they're trying to get in [ __ ] close
they've encountered the other team good
that's perfect
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up because I put it on
single and it was super zoomed in and I
was like I could have easily gone to him
yeah do you have any Red Bull
thank you big oh he's on the balcony
again he's on the balcony again if we
stay apart from each other though
grenades can't kill us do you have a
need yeah throw it on the balcony he's
there
I'm think he's on the balcony I'm not
sure well let's see one go
I've only got smokes I think if they
threw another one
I'm just gonna watch the inside of the
house you try and watch the outside of
the house I'm sure it's really hard oh
yeah yeah I see him he's on this side I
can't shoot he's too close to the house
I wish I got another team coming up
there's a team outside running there's a
bunch of [ __ ] people outside they're
in ok
one down nice [ __ ] that move good the
other guy's gonna get us from the other
[ __ ] balcony that was the worst [ __ ]
I've ever [ __ ] seen no I'm down he's
really hot
you can either pick me up or get in but
you need to do one now come here
tell me if it's coming just get on to
the stairs he's coming he's coming
yeah just give you a nice under there
they've left yeah join me I don't
I only have bandages I'm gonna I'm gonna
fall bill and then I think they ran away
okay
[ __ ] I can't believe [ __ ] that up other
teams here okay go and sit on the stairs
and just bandage nine his bandages
why are you can listen that door good is
this
no I'm saying hey cuz they're coming
they're coming they're [ __ ] crazy
I [ __ ] them up boys they didn't have
me once he's doing what I just did for
them
nice there's other teams running in
we shoot everyone is here
this is [ __ ] chaos okay I'm up
starting again trying to look out I
think one of them have it
[ __ ] me men this is [ __ ] crazy
how is everyone going here oh uh we're
just outside of the circle or we just in
it can you check the map
depends of where we are in the building
the building's half in yeah well that's
good though because this is the best
building ever for that little side [ __ ]
he's coming upstairs down one down I'll
go in no no worth it out he's a quick
Adam he's dead oh nice okay real quick I
gotta hear you got a little bit on me
I [ __ ] shotgun are you looting yeah
madness you crying
okay didn't have much bandages a little
too helmet you [ __ ] beauty pan SKS
[ __ ] there's no one have [ __ ]
painkillers
alright yeah I've got something kept on
to these stairs this is the safest place
all right one first aid kit thank you to
energy drinks and one painkiller nice so
I do I take the painkiller take a
painkiller and yet but use bandages now
because we're relatively safe so don't
waste the first-aid kits we might want
it in the table I just want full health
yeah paint bandages press f9 until you
get up to the 75% yeah I have blues
company to get to the second floor
second sorry yeah damn hittin it because
we can jump out of that look okay listen
this time yeah guitars to do tube right
there
where are you them wherever Oh outside
running up the hill they're trying to
come in or and they're gonna walk past
if they walk past weekend sure they
might just died to the blue
that's insane where do we go now cuz
that feel this [ __ ] open there's a
guy over there's a guy that's gathered
for him got two shots on him
[ __ ] he went behind the rock okay he's
in the circle but he has the advantage
here it sucks oh he's trying to shoot
he's got other people shooting him nice
to [ __ ] when did you find that rock
there the point you won that one you're
the point of one that's not good
let's not get blindsided on him though
10 alive that's a lot of people yeah
people know we're in here as well oh
yeah when do we go that's the question
and where do we go the last second we go
take a painkiller now yeah I did and
take the energy gig now
cuz they stack no yeah I'm already
stacked yeah they're shooting him the
question is should we wake up there is
god him he's dead jump jump out jump out
the rock is claimed by the way who okay
I'm gonna go in the shadow and lay down
I'm gonna hope this tree is in I think
it is could be death Oh
I think someone's shooting at me I'm not
sure yeah now I'm safe but you should
[ __ ] lay down dude what are you doing
wait I need to know if the trees in it's
not [ __ ] I can run to this tree I'm
not going anywhere right now
yeah you say that what you're insane
where are they I don't see anyone he is
by this big rock in front of me encanta
worried about him don't worry about him
you just worry about yourself for now
okay I don't see anyone this is insane
it's hard to see throughout the blue
yeah it really is
oh no he's shooting you yeah where
there's a [ __ ] sniper hmm I don't
know where he is I'm scared about him
well you're in the right spot no you're
not actually that tree right there it's
like the best bye [ __ ] I don't know what
the [ __ ] to do just stay there
21 seconds and you got to run in anyway
so no
madness I can't see anyone
it's [ __ ] oh there there I see one
two seconds run
he's running by that tree everyone is
shooting me [ __ ] everyone is showing
yeah Oh kill run there's another one
over there
well did you kill the one by the tree
I'm alive somehow where are they
we're right in the middle right in the
middle northwest straight ahead of where
I'm facing see my facing no okay I see
it he's up there he's just on top of
that hill he's the last one alive
you versus him go now go now facing me
wait I'm gonna distract him I'm gonna
crawl towards him he's crawled that he's
behind that bush that bush in front of
me he's facing you wait I can't see no I
see him I see him I see him he's calling
I'm gonna wait him out he's gonna cross
that bush just fire into the bush any
second now
never grenade no
stand up and shoot into the bush no do
not move he doesn't know you're there
for what about you're saying that was
awesome [ __ ] nice good job you two
men hell yeah we weirdly enough that
[ __ ] house man
that for house bidding perhaps led the
circle landed on the house apart from
his last a little bit hell yeah that's
the second one yeah splitting up and he
saw me he knew I was saying we were
bullshitting he I he potato aim - [ __ ]
how are you there he was he was up first
and aim they like he ad estan you first
yeah and yet still lost
what a [ __ ] scrub did you see his
name call him out send him a tweet I'll
learn I'll edit it it's so easy to easy
anything nice good job are you going
home now no hell no we're just getting
started